esto es lele gozo una ciudad de 30.000
habitantes al sur de París Después de
varias noches de disturbios violentos en
los que los alborotadores destrozaron
las puertas de vidrio del ayuntamiento
en un intento de incendiar su interior
el alcalde
instaló un perímetro de barricadas
rematado con alambre de Púas esa Barrera
se puso a prueba el viernes por la noche
cuando los alborotadores intentaron una
vez más entrar antes de que llegara la
policía
estaba en mi oficina en el segundo piso
allí en mis 39 años aquí nunca había
tenido tanto miedo como anoche
pero lo peor estaba por venir a la 1:30
de la madrugada del domingo mientras el
alcalde nuevamente pasaba la noche
dentro del ayuntamiento los atacantes
condujeron un automóvil a través de la
verja de su domicilio familiar y le
prendieron fuego mientras intentaban
forzar la puerta en el interior dormían
su esposa y sus dos hijos que sufrieron
heridas mientras subían aterrorizados
por el muro de su jardín
Cuando se escapó la esposa del alcalde
se lastimó la tibia Parece ser una
lesión bastante grave ya que
Aparentemente está rota
dada la extrema gravedad de lo ocurrido
se ha tomado la decisión de calificarlo
como tentativa de homicidio en un
comunicado jimbron dijo que su
determinación de servir a la República
es más fuerte que nunca los disturbios
de esta semana han tenido como objetivo
a varios alcaldes franceses este ensamúa
al noreste de París decidió enfrentarse
a los alborotadores mientras a su
alrededor estallaban fuegos artificiales
de mortero